let's think about the payoff diagram for
just owning the stock or we could say
going long the stock which is really
just owning it if we think about just
the underlying asset value and we're
talking about the value at some date and
you know when traditionally we're
talking about some maturity date for
some options but the value at maturity
but it's some date we have in our mind
so the if we're thinking about just the
value if on that date the underlying
stock price is 50 then the value of
holding the stock is going to be 50 if
the if the value of the underlying stock
is zero then the value of owning stock
is going to be zero if the value of the
underlying stock is 70 then the value of
the stock is going to be 70 so you just
have this very simple line payoff
diagram it's just whatever the
underlying stock price that is the value
of the asset because you just own the
stock if you think about it from a
profit-and-loss point of view you break
even if on that day since you're paying
$50 per share for it today if on
whatever date we're talking about the
stock price at some future date at
maturity for some for some type of
option you paid 50 if the value is 50
then you're at breakeven if the value is
at zero then you just lost $50 so your
going to be at negative 50 over here if
the value of the stock price on that
days goes to 60 70 80 90 100 then you
just made $50 so it's going to be this
point right up here the your profit will
be 50 so you see a payoff diagram that
looks something like this and once again
the only difference between this payoff
diagram and that bet payoff diagram is
that this one right here is shifted down
by $50 to incorporate the price that you
paid for it now let's say this is what
happens if you just buy the stock and
let's say you want to buy the stock but
you want to mitigate your downside risk
you want to buy some insurance on your
stock you want to mitigate the downside
so what you can do is you can literally
just also buy a put option maybe with a
strike price right at 50 you want to
mitigate your down your downside if the
stock goes below 50 and if you do that
and I'll only do it on this payoff
diagram you could just shift it down for
this one
what would it look like well just the
put options payoff diagram looks like
this we've already drawn let me try to
do that in the color of the put option
we've already done that in a previous
video it looks something like this if
the underlying stock price is
then the put options worth 50 because
you can buy it for zero buy the stock
for zero and then you have the right to
sell it for 50 and then the value of the
put option it's worthless if the stock
can actually be sold for 50 then you
wouldn't exercise the put option but
what happens if you own both if you own
both at maybe the maturity of the option
if the stock is worth zero your stock
part is worth zero but the options worth
50 so the combination is going to be
worth 50 if the stock is worth 25 if the
stock is worth 25 then the put option is
also worth 25 so if you own both of them
the combination is going to be worth 50
if the stock is worth 50 the put option
is worth 0 you own the combination it's
going to be worth 50 anything above 50
the put option is just worth 0 but then
you have the value of the stock so the
stock plus the put would look like this
payoff diagram would just look like this
payoff diagram right over here so when
you look at this what happened is we'll
get all of the upside if the stock goes
above 50 but we've mitigated our
downside this is this right here is the
stock plus the put option and what you
see here is that the foot is acting as
insurance when people talk about buying
insurance on a position they're usually
talking about buying a put option and of
course when if we were to draw the same
graph over here
we would shift it down by the amount you
pay for the stock and for the ten
dollars that you're paying for the put
option so you would shift this graph
down by $60 because that's what it did
pay what it cost to go into this
position